bryce wilson who's got the ball for the
braves it's the third rookie in a row
for atlanta what do you expect from
bryce in the nightcap well i want to see
him go out there and attack the zone we
saw what he was capable of doing last
year in the postseason when he went out
and just attacked and was on the attack
through fastballs got after it i want to
see him go out there and do that tonight
i think at times like a lot of these
young guys bryce goes out there and he
kind of gets a little bit timid kind of
pitches not to make mistakes follow
tookies lead go out there get after
these guys trust yourself and give the
team a chance to win so no place to put
eric hosmer the padres trying to put a
crooked number on the board before the
fans have settled into their seats osmer
lifts a fly ball to left field sending
arcia back it'll take him almost to the
track makes the catch tagging at third
and scoring his grisham and the padres
take a one-nothing lead tatis tagged up
two and he gets over to third base
as well as cronerwood tagging up and
getting to second
and the padres strike first on top one
nothing sac fly for eric hosmer will
myers 12 homers and 44 driven in yanks
that one to the backstop and it's gonna
bounce around here comes fernando throw
the plate safe he got in padres take a
two-nothing lead
bounced around a bit fernando wasn't
sure who's gonna try it he does and gets
in so the padres have runners on first
and second one out now a two nothing
lead kim swings lines one out towards
the left center field gap that will get
down that should empty the bases
gronnenworth has come in to score will
myers behind him there will not be a
relay to the plate it's a two-run double
for hassan kim and the padres do get
that big hit they were looking for now
four to nothing in the top of the first
big two out two run double for ha sung
kim how about the bottom of the order
doing some damage and once again right
down the middle hassan kim
is all over it crack in the bat
galloping gallo from first base scores
kronerworth scampers in easily there's a
crooked number for you right there
recall from triple a el paso would make
second big league start in game two of
today's double header 20th round back in
2018 out of fordham university
and at san antone
deep in the heart of texas there in
double a 11 starts really nice opponents
batting average at 209 and 55 in the
third innings pitch and freeman takes
right down the middle strike three
called frozen with a fast ball and a
great job by kaneer and caratini kind of
out thinking freddie freeman brisham on
second one out for jake cronin who's
singled and scored in the first inning
lined into center field to base hit
christian's gonna be waved around here
comes the throw from her radio plate it
is up the line and the padres will take
a five-nothing lead
and the padres making bryce wilson pay
for this
walk to begin the inning as grisham
comes in to score and it's five nothing
san diego a lot of traffic on the base
pass in game two early and that's a good
thing
another high change up that's wilson's
secondary pitch
and jake cronenworth we've talked about
him a little bit
given the situation he'll try to take
that ball where it's pitched it's just
not one swing now runners on the corners
one away and horadio the number seven
hitter coming up that is club deep down
the left field line towards the wall and
a one hop the wall in the score with
eases as he all bees cruising into third
base austin reilly and another double
for guillermo horadio
happy hour for guillermo with all these
doubles makes it a 5-1 ball game that's
his 22nd rbi of the year
yeah spinning breaking ball already you
don't miss too many of those how do you
eat an elephant
one bite at a time right that's it i
think that's your favorite line that i
throw out you got a lot of them but that
that one's at the top of the list now
runners on second and third for orlando
arson line drive to right that'll score
another run
myers on the running track that will
bring home riley already attacks and
moves up give garcia his ninth rbi
and the braves coming back now it's a
5-2 game runner third two down for
eighty five two padres here in the
second hammer and another one a base and
it's a 5-3 game
adrianza on his way to second a pinch
hit double we're back in the game it's
five to three
got a pitch he could handle drove it
down a left field line for a double and
a big two out rbi
well it doesn't matter too does it tom
left-handed right-handed that down and
in spot is always a sweet spot for a
lefty or righty alike yeah and look
particularly with two strikes when
you're
lefty on righty righty on lefty you're
throwing that breaking ball coming into
guys with two strikes out of the top of
the order to jack peterson round ball
left side that has eyes and a base hit
here comes eighty he will score how
about a one run ball game settle in
because i think we're on the verge of a
wild one here in the second game of this
doubleheader another two-strike hit
that's 24 of them and two in a row in
this inning and the braves just need to
go up there and swing at the first two
pitches no matter where they are get the
two strikes
and then go to work
[Applause]
two-strike hitting has been
uncanny on this homestead
it seems so simple but i know it's not
put it in play and see what happens
padres have made their second double
switch of the game as tommy pham comes
in to play left field bottom of the
fourth inning first between el monte
ground ball third base kim's got to
second one cronin north to first in time
look for a moment like hospital might
have come off the bag to receive that
throw for the first base umpires nick
marley said he got him an inning ending
5-4-3 double play as tim hill comes out
of the bullpen to get two outs on just
one pitch and jake cronin worth will
lead it off for the padres three four
five in their order grounded to the left
side against the ship backhanded by
swanson throws across his body and got
him what a play
dansby swanson had to go way to his
right to backhand the ball
and did a good job just to glove it
and then with his momentum going to the
third base line he threw across his body
and got the out they have just made an
announcement that this game has been
suspended in atlanta
as uh after we just surpassed a
three-hour delay mark in this game
it is an hour rain delay as it turns out
get underway here at about 6 15 was
supposed to be 5 15. we're ready to go
so as the suspended game
back uh back in atlanta is about to
resume here in san diego two on one out
brings up angie albies
to left and coming is fam and he'll get
there to make the catch for out number
two
two down swanson at second freeman at
first that'll bring up austin riley
andre's on top right now five four
riley goes around and strikes out pierce
johnson gets him to end the inning
padres five braves four bottom of the
sixth inning bases empty one down for
adam duvall
swing and a high fly ball deep left
field that one is going to go adam
duvalla pitch it homer ties it he did
not miss that inside fastball great job
by adam duvall getting it started tying
the ball game up he goes yaya
unbelievable will smith it's a my game
at home if you will we're going to lead
it off
driven to deep center field
the ball going back and that ball is
gone home run for fernando
padres take a 6'5 lead gets it off the
closure for the braves
this ball was laced off the bat of
fernando tatis junior game tying run
aboard at first and that'll bring up all
these padres trying to nail down game
one
fly ball left field mariznick moving
back to the warning track to make the
catch in front of the wall the padres
win
albies gives it a ride but it's out
number three in the end of the ball game
you